this is dave dewitt filling in for
reviewer richard wakeley
tango game works the evil within and its
sequel are quintessential shinji makami
games brazenly following in the
footsteps of resident evil 4 by mixing
survival horror and action with an
over-the-shoulder perspective the studio
was never meant to be an avenue for
mikami's own creative vision though
tango was established with the aim of
showcasing new and talented young
creators and ghostwire tokyo is the
first game to really demonstrate this
aspiration there's nothing else that can
compare to its peculiar brand of open
world exploration and supernatural
combat as it borrows familiar elements
and combines them with new ideas in
imaginative and surprising ways they may
stumble at times but the sheer
creativity and attention to detail
exhibited throughout constantly shine
through
ah
[Music]
ghost why tokyo story begins at a rapid
pace with one of its protagonists lying
dead on the floor after being involved
in a fatal car accident on tokyo's
famous shibuya scramble crossing akitu
azuki is brought back from the dead when
a shadowy spirit calling himself kk
merges with his body the unholy union
between the pair gives akito access to
kk's supernatural powers but before he's
even able to fathom what in the hell is
going on the rest of tokyo's residents
are engulfed by a malevolent fog that
blankets the entire city a menagerie of
evil spirits known as visitors now roam
shibuya streets in their stead so it's
up to akito and kk to put stop to the
masked villain responsible before the
situation worsens
both protagonists have different
motivations for embarking on this
dangerous quest beyond their
responsibility to save the world kk is
seeking revenge while akito is desperate
to save his younger sister after she's
kidnapped by the villain for nefarious
purposes the relationship between akito
and kk is the strongest aspect of
ghostwater tokyo's narrative as their
budding relationship takes center stage
and develops naturally over the course
of the game the incidental banter
between the pair adds levity to what is
oftentimes bleak subject matter and it's
easy to become invested in their
predicament even when the mysteries
surrounding kkk's past
the rest of the cast isn't given enough
screen time to really stand out or
cultivate any kind of attachment so
attempts to land an emotional payoff are
stunted aquito's sister mari is a prime
example of this as she's more of a plot
device than an actual character the
villain is severely underutilized too
his motives make him potentially
sympathetic but instead he's one note
and completely forgettable as a result
the story shortcomings are disappointing
considering the early potential of its
alluring mysteries but even this isn't
enough to detract from ghostwire tokyo's
fantastic combat setting and
worldbuilding when kk entwined with his
body akito gained access to supernatural
powers known as ethereal weaving
granting him the ability to unleash
projectiles from his fingertips ghostway
tokyo foregoes physical firearms instead
akito is constantly contorting his
fingers and performing the finger
gymnastics required to conjure spectral
powers you start the game with access to
wind weaving allowing you to pelt
tokyo's invading spirits with neon gusts
of wind but by the end of the second
chapter you'll add both fire and water
weaving to your repertoire the former
unleash is a destructive missile that
deals heavy damage while the latter's
horizontal burst and widespread make it
an obvious shotgun analog each flick of
the finger discharges these soaring
projectiles that collide with the
palpable ferocity sending vibrant
particles scattering into the sky combat
takes a while to find its stride and
feels stilted for the game's first
couple of hours mainly because the rate
of wind weaving is painstakingly low
once you start delving into iquitos
skill tree however this gradually begins
to change increasing the rate of fire
does wonders to the sense of impact and
satisfaction that comes from rapidly
blasting enemies away and the combat's
dynamism only continues to grow once you
unlock more powers you'll start
utilizing water weaving in close
quarters to pulverize multiple enemies
at once propel fire weavings flaming
area of attack to damage some of the
game's toughest foes and throw magic
talismans to lock visitors in place a
significant reason why combat feels so
gratifying is because of the way enemies
react to your attacks you might be
fighting apparitions that have some
basis in japanese folklore but you're
constantly ripping off these digital
chunks to reach the inner core festering
below the surface all of the enemy
designs feel like a reflection of tokyo
and its people meshing modernity with
the past just as towering skyscrapers
cast shadows over traditional shinto
shrines so too do these evil spirits
emerge from contemporary issues the
faceless umbrella wielding visitors are
born from the hearts of those pushed to
exhaustion by their work while their
headless spirits scurrying around the
city in school uniform are derived from
the anxieties of students ghostway tokyo
isn't a particularly scary game yet the
atmosphere it conjures is unmistakably
eerie an empty city is always going to
be inherently unnerving but especially
one as populated and dense as tokyo this
isn't your typical post-apocalyptic
metropolis either as shibuya's residents
have only recently vanished there are
still signs of life everywhere you look
with music emanating from the innards of
karaoke bars led billboards illuminating
the rain-soaked urban sprawl convenience
stores welcoming your patronage with a
merry jingle and discarded clothes shoes
umbrellas and phones strewn across the
floor left behind by those consumed in
the fog one glance at the map is enough
to incur the dread of open world fatigue
yet for all its myriad icons the
majority of them simply represent shops
that you can visit to purchase healing
items exploration never feels
overwhelming mainly because you gain
access to section of the city in
bite-sized chunks by cleansing corrupted
torii gates throughout shibuya you'll
gradually disperse the harmful fog and
reveal new side missions and
collectibles these optional quests are
concise vignettes that usually revolve
around helping spirits that are trapped
in a state of limbo this might include
recovering cursed objects that were sold
by a second-hand shop searching an
otherwise quiet neighborhood for a
source of ominous piano music and
investigating a construction site where
a rash of mysterious deaths have
occurred you can typically complete
these side missions in a few minutes and
their quality fluctuates wildly from one
to the next at their best you'll unravel
a compelling paranormal mystery that
mixes combat and exploration at their
worst you'll be thrown into a bland
arena battle or have to tail a yokai for
what feels like an eternity these side
missions are never outright bad and they
typically shed knowledge about a
particular facet of japanese folklore
but too many of them lack depth and feel
like they were included just to pad out
the open world activities
finding out that anurakabe is
essentially a big mattress that enjoys
impeding pathways or that a kappa can't
resist a good cucumber it's part of what
makes exploring ghostway tokyo's open
world such a joy you can pet feed and
read the thoughts of dogs for example
and spiritual cats now run all of the
city's convenience stores because they
need to earn enough money to purchase
catnip you'll also use what's known as a
katashiro to consume friendly spirits
and then feed them into a magic pay
phone to save them in exchange for money
and xp and it all makes complete sense
because tango gameworks has established
such a tangible sense of place ghost why
tokyo doesn't reinvent the wheel when it
comes to open world games but its unique
setting tremendous attention to detail
and singular combat makes it stand out
amongst its contemporaries the story
stumbles and not all of the side
missions are particularly engaging yet
these aspects are easy to push to the
back of your mind when you're using
finger guns to tear through corrupted
spirits with dazzling aplomb shinji
mikami is a legendary director but
taking a backseat and letting new voices
come to the fore has really paid off
[Applause]
[Music]
thundero